I lost 20 pounds this winter from going vegan but can't put weight back on. I feel like my metabolism
is on hyperdrive and I am cakexia. I think I answered this question last week, but
is there a way to reverse this and gain the weight and muscle? I'm sticking to the diet you gave me
and eating as much as possible. Yeah go back to the blog search that word cakexia and I think I have a
video and a bunch of different things to do if you truly do have cakexia. Even if you have,
so I mean cakexia is to find that you're losing 2 to 5 pounds a week no matter what you're doing
you can't you're in this plummet of weight loss. But I doesn't sound like that's what it is maybe
you lost the 20 pounds you feel like you're underway, you're stable now but you want to gain weight back
you can still go to the blog and search cakexia because there's things that you can do and follow
in there that can help you gain what's on weight back on.